por venir
turquía ahora mismo está en un papel muy
complicado en todos los países porque
tiene una relación muy estrecha con
ambos tanto económica y militar como
diplomáticamente turquía está muy unida
a aquí es ya moscú ahora mismo por
ejemplo turquía se muestra con tarea
esta pasión rusa de ucrania del gobierno
turco asegura que esta invasión es una
invasión una guerra algo que rusia
evidentemente ha niega además por esto
mismo turquía está mandando ayuda
humanitaria además de vendiendo muchos
drones que están siendo usados en el
terreno de combate en un cannes sin
embargo turquía no quiere enemistarse
con rusia por muchísimos motivos sobre
todo por materia económica en donde
turquía ahora mismo está sufriendo una
crisis económica muy fuerte que no puede
permitirse el gobierno turco en dañar
más sus relaciones y por lo tanto
turquía están negándose completamente a
aplicar sanciones y medidas punitivas en
contra de moscú con quien quieren dicen
ellos mantener sus cuentas de diálogo
pero sobre todo el gran motivo por el
que turquía no quiere enemistarse con
rusia es por la guerra de siria donde
ambos gobiernos apoyan a facciones
distintas y turquía teme que un
recrudecimiento de este conflicto pueda
llevar a millones de refugiados
que ya cruzaron esta frontera con
turquía en 2015 vuelvan a hacerlo ahora
mismo lo que provoca una crisis política
en turquía
más casos un año y unos pocos meses de
unas elecciones que se prevén muy duras
para la receta de perdonan cuyo gobierno
está en mínimos de popularidad
históricos